fresh off Sun is going down right here
middle California a your boy Bordeaux it
is what it is is what we do how a 60s
all right shotgun in an old school with
my dad I grew up in for a high I
remember when I was a kid pops always
said one day without doing the car
together probably no letters are my
friends daddy me and my homies we've
never been to Mexico no or Spanish ain't
person but you can find those partying
with the hipsters in Echo Park chillin
at the skate park invented or doing
karaoke and k-town but for kids like me
sometimes we do end up tonight a talk
with them yeah we taco why not right it
was up to my pops I be fixing cars at a
shop all day I got the whole city is my
hammer I put up my our free money on
got an idea with this cause you're
friendly writing your name and other
people's property jail an ounce of shame
or criminal problem you know people call
me now ghost because for the last eight
years you haven't so much and mentioned
like things to remind people that I use
her joke and nothing changes how do you
son I can't talk to my son
they just don't want anything to do with
me why don't you kids you don't stop
trying
hey no no pants on a panel on the
shoulders up against anything on it
posted over the next minute possible to
my left hand famous / CD artist don't
have to be poor to be real that is your
heritage helping you know nothing about
I guarantee I'm gonna make over my life
you